[Music]
it was important for us to make sure
that we served the story that the book
told us you didn't have to change the
truth you just had to pick what parts of
the story you were going to
tell it was very obvious that George he
really got the spirit of the book the
boys that boat so got Joe rant he wanted
to meet me he talk about how he had
joined the crew at the University of
Washington I said Joe can I write a book
about your life and he said no but you
could write a book about the boys who
had rode with him you're all here
because we're looking for the eight most
qualified young men to fill out JV
bat we worked with Mark Smith and he
wrote a terrific screenplay if it had
been fiction I probably would have
pulled back because no one's going to
buy that this could have happened I got
9 seconds under the course record it is
true you don't root for the guy who has
everything you root for the guy that was
cleaning the Dugout I've never had so
many people come up to me and and tell
me when can I see it we had to screen it
for the author and there's Dan crying
that really made us feel like we did the
right thing if it could touch me it's
going to touch a lot of viewers look at
Washington I don't believe what I'm
seeing those nine boys that came
together in that boat were the greatest
rowers in the world but what was really
spectacular is they did it out of
necessity it drives their story and it
drives this film as
as